[Applause]
I loved I loved this tweet you wrote
before the Grammys I believe about
designers who said she was too big for
them to dress her tweet literally said
I'm sorry I had to get this off my chest
if you didn't like my fashion or style
or my music that's one thing but don't
say you can't dress someone that isn't
runway size we are beautiful any size
small or large and my size 8s is still
going to the grammy size 8 size 8 on a
good day
ok ok cuz I was about to be like first
of all yeah I know I'm the burden of
size a it's so hard you ever go to
fittings and they bring is designer
things that they make him like size zero
and it's like I can't even get on like
one leg bro and they're like it fits I'm
like it doesn't fit and then I put it on
and then I rip it and then you got to
buy it here's the thing it's not that
anybody's against skinny people it's
just we don't we don't get a lot of
pressure I think that's more a thing
that happened that happens more in
sports like if guys it's about getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
but we typically it's a real double
standard we don't get it all of the the
value that should be put in somebody
should just simply be put in what they
do and the essence of who they are
remember you can't quantify I think I
think people feel comfortable and they
can quantify something and you can't
quite
I say it every day for my show because
you know the shows are always like young
girls young guys you know or daughters
with their mother mothers and daughters
and I and I say it every name I show I
say I don't care what anybody has told
you a number doesn't define you and I
think it's really important for my fans
to know that that I'm not trying to be
that I don't care it's like I'm cool and
you have a bangin body
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this